There are actually several ways in which
Objective C can be characterized as more
dynamic than Swift.
The second has to do with how objects
are bound to the methods they invoke.
In Swift, method binding or method
resolution happens at compile time.
In Objective C,
methods in the objects invoking
them are not bound until runtime.
Let's imagine another array
holding objects of multiple types.
This time we have objects belonging to
the classes Puppy, Drum and Dealer.
Now let's imagine that we choose
an item from this array and
invoke the method, play.
Now, these three items actually
implement the method play in
three different ways,
which play the code is referring
to isn't known at compile time.
Coupling of method and
object doesn't happen until runtime.
And if we look in
the console we see Frolick.
Okay, that was Spot, the Puppy.
And if we run it again we see,
Here's a card.
Okay, that was the Dealer.
And if we run it again,
we see ba-doom-cha, that was the Drum.